lots of talk about of course we're still
in the midst of a global pandemic which
is why we're here in this theater and
you may have seen a lot of the critical
data being charted and graphed by the
CDC now I mentioned this recently some
of these graphs I mean I'm just so
confusing they were getting bombarded
with graphs all the time you don't know
what they mean and adding to that some
of the graphs people are putting out
just seem a little unnecessary for
example check this one out there's been
a 60% increase in people eating morning
lasagna is that something we need to
know I don't know it's a good idea
true check this out a five hundred and
fifty percent increase in women named
Karen going by their middle name yeah
there's a seven thousand percent
increase in Americans googling Canadian
citizenship there's an 80 percent
increase in routing for the sharks
during Shark Week I guess I guess we've
all we're all sick of humans right now
come on I mean the shake let the sharks
have one that's one shark week let the
Sharks win you're right I I think
let's hope they win this week hey
seventy five percent increase in board
game related stabbings I can understand
that
yeah a six hundred percent increase in
adults overheard yelling
hope your haircut was worth it dad I was
kind of a grim one yeah yeah
unless dad cut his own hair hey this one
just says data don't know what to do
with that one hey check this out a
steady increase in kovat infections per
item of Tommy Bahama clothing owned that
one will get cut
here we see the answer to the question
why are we having cereal for dinner
mommy 20% because mommy's on a zoom 80%
because mommy had gin for breakfast
mommy's an alcoholic
that's the joke there is that one to end
on maybe not but we're in an abandoned
theater and we're losing our minds
don't say abandoned the owners right
here it's abandoned Jesus he doesn't own
anything but that Cadillac and it's
probably rented have a Guinness at 9:00
in the morning says planning